why are you getting out of the car sir
i'm not sitting
i got shit
[Music]
in the airport
with tom henry ocean robert edward one
[Music]
hello
monster i will be placed on it that's
why i'm stopping you the speed 57 and
35.
you're going 57 in a 35 serve if you
have your driver's license between
prevention
why are you getting out of the car sir
twelve radio this meal just stepped out
of the vehicle
step over here now
have a seat on the ground
have a seat
i'm not sitting
i got shit
back off back up i'm not sitting
motherfucker
touch the vehicle put your hands on the
vehicle now
what's up
radio send me units
roll over on your stomach now
knock it off man
knock it off now
get your arm behind you
put it up
shut up
you don't do that to a woman
do you understand me
or not you don't do that to a woman
detained at this time
rolling your side
stand up
walk back to my car